let's get right down to it right now um
what is the significance of jamie
spears's filing in court yesterday
so jamie spears's filing yesterday was
very big it was the first time he's
publicly said that he's willing to step
down but it's important to know that
he's not gone yet he says he'll only
step down when the time is right aka
when they resolve some outstanding
issues involving brittany's money
right um the filing does say that he's
willing to transition when the time is
right as you said so what do you think
is his strategy in doing that
it's really hard to know what his
strategy is but he appears to say the
issues that he wants resolved before he
steps down involved his management of
britney's money in 2019 and also any of
the final legal bills if you've been
following the case you know that britney
is having to pay for jamie's very
expensive lawyers so it seems that
that's something he wants
um there's also
the person that brittany's lawyer has
appointed to or nominated to take over
the conservatorship is a forensic
accountant that stands out a little bit
to me but what do you make of that i
mean do you think that he could jamie
spears could face charges at some point
i mean it's very possible the new
conservator of the estate would be a
forensic accountant whose resume is full
of all sorts of financial investigations
and britney's lawyer yesterday in a
statement said that he wants to depose
jamie spears so it seems that you know
they want to do a full investigation of
him
um jamie's lawyer
made a number of attacks against britain
herself talking about her
alleged addiction and mental health
struggles and her mother uh lynne with
uh involvement in brittany's life and
what her parenting role has been what do
you make of those why do you think he
might be going that route
that felt very
personal the attacks on britney's mother
lynn who you know recently got involved
in the conservatorship and has been
supporting brittany in court and jamie
went out of his way for the bulk of his
court filing was directed at attacks on
lynn saying you know she hasn't been
involved in brittany's life she doesn't
know what's going on you know she wrote
a book many years ago exploiting
britney's pain so it felt very nasty
right
um
why do you think that britney's lawyer
is
this is more of a larger picture
question but why do you think that he's
looking to file to remove jamie first
rather than what we know is britney's
stated wish which is to terminate the
conservative outright
so we don't know for sure but a lot of
people speculate that this is a first
step towards examining the
conservatorship as a whole and it would
be a lot easier to terminate the
conservatorship if you get rid of jamie
as conservator so that he cannot object
to any wish from brittany to end it
is there anything about the timing of
this that seems interesting to you or is
this just kind of
the timing was very strange to me you
know just a few days ago the judge had
ruled um against britney's lawyer's
request uh to move up the hearing in
which they were going to decide whether
or not jamie should go
um so it felt very surprising that kind
of out of nowhere jamie's lawyer filed
this petition saying you know hey he's
willing to go
eventually if we get these things
resolved
right um in light of that uh decision by
the judge earlier this week there have
been a lot of death threats harvard
against her supposedly and things on
social media being said we know there's
been a lot of public interest in this
case especially in the last few months
and to your credit largely because of
your documentary um we've seen
celebrities talking about this now of
course fans but we've also seen as we
see as i said the negative side of this
and people facing death threats and
things like that do you think that the
media interest in this case right now is
helping or hurting britney's case
i would think that the media interest is
helping in that you know britney said on
june 23rd in her court speech that she
had never spoken about this before
because she didn't feel she was believed
or she would be believed so i think to
the extent that the media has helped
raise awareness of this and validate a
lot of the claims that she has made um i
think that has you know helped
i also want to ask about brittany's
children because uh her father the
children had a restraining order against
her father taken out in 2019 by their
father kevin federline um
with all of this going on right now do
you know anything about kind of where
things stand with the kids whether in
relation to brittany or just in general
no other than you know brittany appears
to love them very much and as you note
you know jamie has had or there's been a
restraining order against jamie um from
seeing his grandkids britney's kids for
uh over two years now
right
um i think that's everything on mind is
anything else you think i missed or
should touch on
um i would just note that something else
that's really surprising is just how
quickly things are moving now and have
really escalated you know
brittany for most of the 13-year
conservatorship had one lawyer who was
court-appointed and nothing really
happened in the case and then bam last
month she gets a new lawyer of her
choosing and since then we've seen
momentous change you know as as seen by
yesterday jamie saying hey i'm willing
to step down
you